that's that's all my ink I have this mic
on so yeah that's all right gentlemen
and help me out
can you believe that that didn't work
out
gee I can't believe your relationships
don't work out
uh here I'm getting black you can ask me
about anything you want yeah mine's
lying too of course I'm interested hey
let me help out before you yell at me
there you go the Love Is The Love
by the way dude the Elk's been delicious
thank you how do you like it I've been
chowing it for like four days like out
of respect for that [__] elf that you
shot it's like I'm eating all this [__]
I don't care if it's [__] bad does it
make you more aggressive what no
no Joe you [__] lunatic
[Applause]
somebody gets in my face that that
caused me to get more
a bit of protein
you had to beat the [__] out of people
for like three decades before you could
like chill smoke a little weed put on
your little rascals hat and just [__]
chill out
yeah
you don't understand
I love him to death
but this guy is the most testosterone
[__] filled dude I've ever met that's
why I love him I love him what do you
think about uh population world
population it's completely out of
control
be fruitful and multiply I think we did
that I think we
that goal and it's time to move on to
something else I mean it's just going to
get worse and worse and worse like uh I
think we need to kind of curb the babies
for a minute let some older people die
off you know and uh I don't know I think
I get good numbers about I don't know
about 500 million oh really sound like
the oceans come back yeah but how do you
choose people some space but you're not
you're not talking about death panels
you're just talking about attrition yeah
yes you know birth control then birth
control old people die somebody falls
off a ladder right you gradually you
know you taper it up here's what I think
maybe get rid of seat belts I mean
there's some things we could do to move
them just get rid of medicine get rid of
medicine yeah all these diseases we're
trying to stop is nature actually
keeping us in check but we can
contemplate like love and uh loss in our
own mortality so we think these diseases
are bad they are bad they but animals
get them all the time and it keeps them
in check and we stopped all of that get
rid of medicine get rid of medicine get
rid of a healthy life eat well get rid
of it wasn't for modern medicine I
wouldn't be talking to you right now I
should not be here I had a ruptured
appendix in 1980 I should have died
under a stack of wool blankets on a
prairie but I did eat a green Jello yeah
and no here I am just walking around
taking up space driving a car floating a
river in my own way adding my hole to
the ozone layer the three days of eating
in England I Now understand why Gordon
Ramsay is so [__] mad all the time
the [__] are you doing
dude how bad were those [__] rice
balls
oh my God they were soggy that [__]
Mama Celeste Pizza dude this is funny we
work in this Italian restaurant and I
hear this woman Mumble was good I was
going I go was it good she said it's
unbelievable
then I was like oh [__] I thought they
were Taurus
I don't understand how you can live this
close to France and Italy and [__] up a
[__] pizza and steak as much as they
do but I'll tell you know what it is
because this is what they they focus all
their [__] on the pups their pups are
unbelievable their sports are
unbelievable sense of humor is
unbelievable let the [__] food when
you say there's no reason that kills any
sort of examination as to how two people
ended up at that at that place
you say there's no reason you cut out
the build up you just left with the ACT
how are you going to solve it if you
don't figure it out
look how awkward it is in here right now
I said you shouldn't hit a woman I'm
just saying how come you can't ask
questions you can only ask questions
about what the guy did you can never ask
about the woman why is that
why is that what is that
what is what does answer them right mean
what does that mean are you the idiot
who got up halfway through the special
during the bit and you're like walking
around like I'm not [__] taping a
special here what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you
[__] had to ignore all of that and
now you're gonna like yell out and not
only that yells something that makes no
[__] sense whatsoever
answer him answer him
every [__] special I do there's
always one
it's right down the [__] middle
[Applause]
talking about hitting women sweetheart
and I think you just added another
reason
Jesus [__] Christ
I love this I'm not even in a
relationship with her and she's [__]
nagging me
now we're here I think that's a little
pricey
thank you and you're welcome welcome
letting me know that you appreciated
that
thank you
[Applause]
she has no stairs in her in her house or
someone doesn't know how to walk up them
thank you
[Applause]
she sounded like I was downstairs in the
rec room
changing the fuse or something
[Applause]
this might be the favorite name of
anything I've ever advertised here
uh other than one white Charlie's uh
Sherry's Berries
it says insert story when you've given
or received
uh the gifts
well I I've been out of town I haven't
gotten Sherry's Berries yet everybody
all right Sherry's Berries since the end
of the the year is all about delicious
holiday food why not send an extra
special holiday treat to friends family
business associates Associates everyone
you know I've never met a person who
didn't love Sherry's Berries
send giant dip strawberries from
Sherry's Berries for only 19.99 that's
over a 40 savings go to berries.com
click on the microphone and type in Burr
b-u-r-r for my listeners double the
berries
for just ten dollars more berries are
terrific and a sweet holiday gift they
also have delicious products such as
Christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels
here's the only way to get
this special 1999 Cherries Berries offer
call 866 fruit
I'm sorry
look at myself
prove this this is ridiculous who the
[__] is gonna buy this [__] this is the
funniest [__] I've ever seen
his wife
Christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels
call 866 fruit everybody
it's I'm sorry 866 fruit zero Dash two
or even better visit berries.com
oh punch truck oh please spell out the
words oh by all means berries
b-e-r-r-i-e-s berries click on the
microphone on the top right corner and
type in Burr
you've got to see these enormous berries
for yourself
God I swear to God this is the copy go
to berries.com click on the microphone
and tip and Burr type in Burr dip your
balls and dip your berries in that don't
wait now order or have some chocolate
berries for the [__] person in your
life
oh [__] I needed that that was wonderful
I'm sure I'll get some complaints on
that one we need a conference call
can't do it I'm gonna Helsinki hey you
[__] better buy some Sherry's Berries
because I'm gonna get in trouble for
that [__] reading I'm not changing it
because that was hilarious
um uh
wiping tears away here
um
I was at a party with
I noticed you first and you return
you took me to that room like a dream
come true the dance you perform was just
for me you kisses on the neck then you
work your way down Let Yourself Go for
me all around time seductively still
performing for me give into that thirst
for the energy burp are you with your
girlfriend living yes I am I'm
technically married but I'm married how
like I want to be married yeah which is
I don't sign that Behind the Music
contract where you know everything works
out until it doesn't work yeah no you
see Sugar Shane Mosey one of the
greatest boxers of all time he's losing
his championship belt in a divorce
oh that's losing yeah it's like you're
trying to break a man why does she want
those
she's gonna break them they go with
their shoes
[Laughter]
divorce all of a sudden it costs like 50
Grand a month to give a kid Froot Loops
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just not being addressed on any level
what are you talking about what do you
know what am I talking about every guy
out there is just getting that nobody's
safe
but you are prayers
Arnold Schwarzenegger's made is still
called the maid in the story she knew
his wife on a first name basis hooked up
with this dude in their bed and is still
called the maid why did she bang him why
it's easier because of that 1987 flat
top He's Still rocking right
you don't think it's because of that
Kindergarten Cop money he's got laying
around
I'm Not Innocent I'm not condoning
what the man did but you know there just
needs to be guys need to be educated
there's nothing out there to help a guy
handle becoming rich and famous for that
that platoon of [__] that's gonna come
over the hill
like like Braveheart faces yes
there's nothing out there
no it's like guys never learn how to
keep themselves in check Society does it
for you yeah just women aren't going to
bang you because you drive the forklift
at Home Depot
that you want to bang all of them
they're not going to do it so you didn't
keep yourself in check the forklift job
did right then all of a sudden you hit a
lot the lottery you know yeah and then
you can just give in to all of that like
I don't I'm so sick of all these trolls
coming on TV
judging these Great Men
these Great Men all these guys anytime
one of these guys gets caught for
screwing around these guys come waddling
out of their cubicles with their joggles
they're absolutely reprehensible
like they have any idea what it's like
to be tempted at that level you know
yeah as you walk over to your Ford Focus
are you really beating these women off
of you all those people who judge Tiger
Woods how many people here at golf
when was the last time you walked off
the 18th hole and there was a busload of
Scandinavian women waiting to hump your
brains out
you know
this is South Side Steep and this is
South Side Steve TV and this is Bill
Burr
that's your question
I'm just saying who you are oh yeah all
right I don't like you creep me out with
that big microphone in that country
western shirt oh no this isn't country
western it's like it's hip now to wear
this this is my nightclub look yeah come
on
all right
yo you're uh what is this rock 10 100.5
this is the worst interview I've ever
done and he's wearing Stetson cologne or
something it's just really over
overpowering you know what he looks like
he looks like the first guy who gets his
ass kicked in a Steven Seagal movie
the background guy behind the uh the big
Kingpin why don't you handle this
I really hope all of you run into all
those black people that you love so much
here in Camden I really hope that
happens I hope there's a line of all you
guys getting [__] carjacked and they
take out their big black dicks and they
just shove them right your [__] miles
each and every one of you and somehow
they just keep repeatingly coming right
in your [__] eyeballs
until it builds up so much that your
eyes click [__] crossover you can't
see [__] and somehow there's another
dick in there for you to suck ten
minutes left
[Applause]
[__] Rocky is your hero the whole
pride of city is built around a [__]
guy who doesn't even exist he's a
[__] Joe Frazier is from there but
he's so you can't [__] deal with them
so you make a [__] statue for some
free foot [__] Italian you stupid
Philly cheesy [__] jackasses I hope
that [__]
that [__] your [__] faces on
all of you collectively suck a [__]
dick